I think you owee it to the American
people to explain why you've gone on Fox
News and told people that while the
president was out of office he he had a
loan with his brother and in a way they
were evading taxes it has come out in
the public that you also do business
with your brother with potential loans
and so since you have framed that and
manipulated that with the American
people that Joe Biden did something
wrong when he wasn't in office I just
would like to know if you would like to
use some of my time I would love I would
love it
okay you retweeted that story completely
false I've never loaned my brother one
penny my father who was a dentist had
some Farmland he died and my brother
couldn't afford he wanted to sell it but
he wanted to keep it in the family so I
bought it from my brother that story
that you tweeted also said how I had a
shell company that is the White
House tried to get CNN to WR that story
they went around and investigated all
this bull that Ian Sams is trying to
tell people the only dumb financially
illiterate people pick up on I went to
the bank and I borrowed money and I
bought that land I didn't get wires from
Romania China my family doesn't get
wires okay never loan my brother
money don't have an LLC but you and
Goldman who is Mr trust fund continue to
my no I'm not going to give you your
time back we can stop the clock you all
continue to you look like a Smurf here
just going around and all this stuff now
listen Mr
chairman here with reaction house
oversight committee chairman James comr
I don't know this might be fight day in
Washington by the looks of it um but In
fairness to you either you did loan
money or you didn't and you're saying
you didn't and if you did in fact there
would be a record of that wouldn't there
sir absolutely I can prove whether I
loan money or whether I received a loan
in about 2 seconds and I wasn't going to
sit there and let moset lie about me and
my family you know we are very
transparent uh I disclose all my
finances uh if they want to come to my
hometown Monroe County Kentucky I told
him I would pay for his plane ticket
we'll drive him around and I'll show him
every piece of Farmland I have and we
can go into great detail about how I
acquired that farm
and if if if it takes me being uh in
front of the house oversight committee
along with the bidens to open up my
books if that's what it'll take to for
them to open up their books then I will
do that I will do whatever it takes to
get the American people answers about
the corruption of this Biden family and
what they're what they're doing Sean is
though Ian Sams is leading this through
their dark money political group out of
the White House they're trying to
discredit me because I continue to
follow the money and provide evidence of
criminal activity by the Biden family
see this is what it really comes down to
is you have the suspicious activity
reports your your committee is
identified uh you have the shell
corporations your committee has
identified you have identified tens and
tens of millions of dollars in payments
to at least 10 Biden family members
including grandchildren including one
family member that admits they're
addicted to crack they got a lot of
money in the energy sector but admits
they have no experience in energy uh you
also caught dead to rights the president
as a candidate and as president lying
about ever talking to his son his
brother or anybody for that matter about
foreign business deals you've identified
phone calls that he's been on with
foreign business partners you've
identified a a specific phone call and a
WhatsApp message where they got $5
million a few days later from a a
Chinese Energy company and then of
course we have the whole barisma mess I
think Mr chairman I think what's going
on here is you're you kind of struck a
nerve and I think the Democrats are
running scared because if what is being
laid out before the American people ends
up to be true there might be a high
probability that Joe Biden is guilty of
bribery and that's what your committee
is looking into isn't it it's what we're
looking into remember we found the FBI
form where one informant uh alleged that
Joe Biden took a bribe now we know there
were many informants that alleged the
Biden took bribes in in countries all
around the world the FBI's covered this
up the doj's covered this up the IRS has
covered this up and thank God for my
house oversight committee and the
members on my committee and our great
staff we continue to follow the money we
continue to uh successfully subpoena
bank records we found that Joe Biden in
fact benefited from this and we're going
to continue to move forward regardless
of what the Biden family and their
friends and the media try to say about
me or my family we're going to get to
the bottom of this and provide
transparency for the American people
about what the Biden family has been up
to and the risk that they posed to our
national security last question random
question so you have this Farm do you
grow anything on it is it a working farm
it's a working farm corn soybeans beef
caddle
Timber anybody that wants to come see it
we'll show it to
them all right chair Mr chairman we
appreciate it hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else